[Musica]
[Applauso]
e
Ciao
ciao 3 2
[Applauso]
[Musica]
è una delle tante volte che mi ritrovo
sul precipizio della montagna e guardo
attraverso l'intera Valle con la mia
tutal
lare mi preparo e ammiro la natura che
mi circonda che Paradiso che mi aspetta
ogni salto da un posto nuovo fa sempre
un po' paura il brivido di non conoscere
e la concentrazione per un salto tecnico
che non si può sbagliare Quando sono
sull'ex faccio un bel
respiro mi sento pronta per volare e poi
giù si
vola una volta che la tuta inizia a
volare è tutto bellissimo Non ci sono
più paure Ma solo forti
emozioni Questa è la sensazione più
bella che provo sentirmi libera essere
sola e me stessa facendo quello che amo
di più
volare dove non ci sono problemi o
preoccupazioni o cose da fare ma l'unica
cosa è godersi completamente e
pienamente un breve momento che per me
sembra
infinito sono nata e cresciuta in un
piccolo paese anziio mia madre e mio
padre non sono stati dei piloti Anzi
avevano paura di prendere l'aereo e
allora vi chiederete come ti è venuta
questa voglia di buttarti giù da tutto
grattacieli montagne Ponti
aeroplani a volte mi faccio anche io la
stessa
domanda
il desiderio che sento di me dentro di
me è un forte richiamo di
avventura la mia immaginazione da
bambina ha voluto rendere possibile e
reale quei racconti Che mi leggeva mio
padre di pirati e di Baleniere di
bambini che volano e restano piccoli per
sempre Poi invece da mia madre ho
imparato il coraggio il coraggio che ci
vuole per andare al pronto soccorso a
lavorare tutti giorni è lì sì che ci
vuole
coraggio crescendo mi sono dedicata a
vari sport dalla danza al kickboxing al
pugilato vedevo i paruisti volare e
volevo diventare una di loro però al mio
paese non c'era una scuola di volo
e fra l'altro la mia famiglia la vedeva
come un'attività molto pericolosa e non
adatta ad una ragazza a 18 anni un mio
amico mi mi fece vedere un video di una
ragazza che danzava in aria E lì ho
capito quale fosse la mia strada nel
paracadutismo il
freestyle lavorando in una pizzeria e
vendendo il mio motorino così ho
iniziato il corso di
paracadutismo civile in un aeroporto
militare dove c'erano solo paracadutisti
più grandi di me avevo appena 18 anni e
solo una donna in più sentirmi dire
sempre sei troppo piccola non sei forte
non ce la farai mai
e molto diverso dal dal volo delle
farfalle che immaginavo nella mia nella
mia
testa Il corso è stato duro e appena
preso il brevetto sono partita per gli
Stati Uniti proprio dalla ragazza che
avevo visto in quel video sono partita
per l'America senza sapere l'inglese con
un biglietto per Miami e i contatti di
un insegnante di Freestyle Stefania
Martinengo che all'epoca era la
campionessa del mondo e e adesso diventò
una delle più più care amiche ancora ci
lanciamo
insieme ho iniziato ad allenarmi tutti i
giorni ho trasformato la mia passione
nella mia professione ho fatto sempre
più lanci quasi 13.000 Oggi ho vinto
gare ho partecipato al record del mondo
europeo e record
italiani come donna in uno sport
prettamente maschile mi sono chiesta se
si potesse portare la femminilità negli
sport
estremi ho portato avanti collaborazioni
con stilisti e campagne di moda mi sono
lanciata con i tacchi
e con vestiti di alta
moda mi sono sentita realizzata non solo
come atleta ma soprattutto come
donna
adesso Vi sembra facile venire qui su
questo palco e raccontarmi la la
realizzazione del mio sogno ma non è
stato così semplice
Anzi ho avuto tante sconfitte delusioni
e mi sentivo sempre non
realizzata e ho pagato tanti prezzi ho
conosciuto la paura e anche il
fallimento quando avevo solo sei lanci e
purtroppo il mio istruttore di teoria ha
avuto un brutto incidente poi negli anni
ho perso tantissimi
amici c'è stato un periodo che non
riuscivo nemmeno più a lanciarmi avevo
tantissima
paura però la mia vita l'ho ripresa in
mano Certo non come prima perché non si
è mai uguali a se stessi Dopo aver
provato il
[Musica]
volo
BL
[Applauso]
to
allora E come avete visto in questo
lancio c'era un bel po' di vento Infatti
mi mi sono spostata subito dopo aver
passato il palazzo
E perché proprio c'era un vento laterale
e solo che era l'unico giorno che si
poteva fare ovviamente abbiam rischiato
un pochino però alla fine è andato bene
volo perché non mi lancio mai
impreparata mi alleno duramente
e uno dei miei progetti preferiti e il
più spettacolare è stato il volo sul
vulcano vigliar
Rica uno dei vulcani più attivi che si
trova a Cile in pcon in Cile a
pcon
[Musica]
C
altezza
2850 m e 200 m di diametro di cratere
sempre in attività volare sopra un
vulcano come potete immaginare
un'esperienza unica sono stata l'unica
donna a farlo e la preparazione richiede
anni e anni di paracadutismo con la con
la tutelare con il mio team videoman e
il mio caro amico Carlos che oggi è qui
con noi in platea dal Venezuela e si è
appena operato alla spalla
Grazie insieme abbiamo studiato Quale
linea di volo fosse più spettacolare per
passare proprio sopra al grande cratere
del vulcano la sera prima Ovviamente ho
avuto un sacco di dubbi e anche degli
incubi di finirci dentro Meno male che
e quando siamo passati sopra il cratere
del vulcano Ho dovuto trattenere il
respiro per non inalare tutti i gas
e siamo anche abbiamo anche galleggiato
proprio per il
calore tutto il tempo durante il volo
nella mia testa avevo solo una parola
Wow Che bellezza il contrasto nero della
terra la neve bianca e poi il fuoco
rosso quando Siamo atterrati riuscivo a
malapena a parlare Ci siamo abbracciati
ed ero Soddisfatta e felicissima di come
fosse andato il volo Tutto perfetto come
L'avevo immaginato una delle avventure
più belle della mia vita con gli anni ho
capito che non sono drogata di
adrenalina ma sono drogata di avventure
[Musica]
We had really good Days with crocodiles
Yesterday was Amazing We had like five
crocodiles in one dive Today We had two
crocodiles very very good
Action I think I and Eli We got Nice
Happy
[Musica]
about
We didn't we
are
e una parentesi su questo video
Eh diciamo una settimana per far queste
foto 8 ore al giorno in acqua con i
coccodrilli che avevano loro paura di me
quindi c'è voluto più tempo di quello
che
immaginavamo oggi da grande ogni tanto
ripenso alla bambina che ero quando mia
mamma mi diceva Non toccare i cani
grossi Beh non aveva parlato di cocco
Illi e
squali e poi quando mi diceva Ma se i
tuoi amici si buttano giù dal ponte lo
fai anche tu eh
sì E adesso si buttano anche i miei
allievi il mio ragazzo e con loro
Condivido un paradiso fatto di Soffici
nuvole Tramonti mozzafiato come quelli
dell'Amazzonia o del Moab negli Stati
Uniti un paradiso fatto di oceani come
le Maldive o la Sardegna
di montagne come le Dolomiti e la
Norvegia di vulcani fumanti di
grattacieli scintillanti di fiumi e
laghi e cascate quando riesco a vedere
tutti questi dettagli della Terra mi
sento fortunata perché ben pochi
Dall'alto sono riusciti a vedere non so
un piccolo Canyon oppure i colori
dell'alba e poi l'erba perfetta per un
atterraggio alla Roberta bambina ho
fatto anche un altro regalo il sogno
diventato realtà di essere una vera e
propria supereroina con tutti i
superpoteri e il pacchetto
completo Nella mia frenetica vita di
lavoro Faccio anche la stun woman
e questa è stata la la realizzazione di
tutti i miei sogni partita come una
giovane ragazza di un piccolo paese del
Lazio fino ad Hollywood sicuramente
senza superpoteri ma solo con una testa
dura e lo obiettivo a fuoco sempre
davanti a me è stato un viaggio a volte
difficile a volte pensavo di non farcela
a volte Volevo smettere ma è stato il
mio viaggio e dopo tanti sacrifici ci
sono riuscita e voi e a voi oggi vi
chiedo quale viaggio vorrete
percorrere quali promesse da voi bambini
vorrete realizzare inalate avventura e
buona
fortuna
D